hey youtubers it's Charlie this is gonna
be a video all about the Suicide Squad
DC's movies vs. TV shows the stars of
arrow were just explaining some of the
big changes behind the scenes that they
had to make way back in season two when
they started to make these new DC movies
so basically what happened is is arrow
had to cancel all of its Suicide Squad
plans as we know since then so I'm gonna
go ahead and say spoilers for arrow up
to what's happened so far so in the past
couple of seasons they've killed off
very notable characters that they
developed over the course of several
seasons the biggest of which is probably
Amanda Waller they killed off Deadshot
they'd spent so much time developing
that he was a big part of diggle's
backstory so if you to ask any fan of
arrow what their favorite season is or
any fan of comic book shows in general
like what is the best season of arrow
they would probably say season two
because it was the culmination of a big
Deathstroke art which was just amazing
Manu Bennett was awesome they had
developed their own Suicide Squad they
were doing so much comic-book stuff in
the back half of that season they even
had their own version of Harley Quinn
but right around the time that they were
making that DC decided to do a Suicide
Squad movie so obviously we know now
they've already finished the movie
because it's a couple years later but at
the time the person in charge of
deciding you know whether or not it was
okay for TV shows to you certain
characters though one of the presidents
of Warner Brothers really high up on the
ladder decided to collectively pump the
brakes on anything Suicide Squad related
on arrow so it's just a big WTF but it
also caused the arrow producers to have
to pivot their plans for season three so
imagine you spend two years and millions
of dollars developing this amazing
rogues gallery of villains to use via
The Suicide Squad they even had a prison
for Task Force X so they call the task
force X on the TV show because they were
being true to the john austrian der
comic he wasn't the first person to work
on Suicide Squad he was just the person
in the 80s that made it famous like when
Frank Miller started writing daredevil
Frank Miller didn't create daredevil but
he made him this amazing character so if
you want to read a Suicide Squad comic
book run just read John Ostrander run
but can you even imagine what they would
have been doing in season 3 if they
still had the Suicide Squad
they were basically getting up to the
point where they were gonna call Task
Force X The Suicide Squad but
unfortunately it didn't go down that way
and now because
seems like they're doing Teen Titans in
the movies were probably never gonna get
to see Deathstroke on the TV show I
think the reason we didn't see more of
him during season 3 is mostly because he
was busy filming other shows
he's a series regular on the shannara
chronicles' so he's a really expensive
actor and I think they didn't want to do
him right away
after almost killing him off at the end
of season 2 so they didn't want to bring
him right back and in the timespan of
season 3 the Suicide Squad movie ramped
up the Teen Titans TV show that was
originally going to be on TNT fell
through so I think DC was like okay
we'll just put some of these characters
in the movies in Deathstroke being a big
Teen Titans character is probably going
to be a part of that but if you talk to
anybody who says that arrow has been
ruined it's really been ruined by the
movies because think about what season 3
would have been like if we would have
had Suicide Squad it would have been so
much better and then they could have
gone into something even more related
even more hardcore in season 4 so really
the single greatest threat to the TV
shows or the movies but you have to hand
it to some of these starts like normally
you don't get a lot of candor from
people like this because they're under a
gag order for threat of being fine money
like if you talk about this in a bad way
we'll find you money Stephen Amell is a
total champ about it he got so many
questions when they announced the
Justice League movie are you gonna be in
it are you gonna be in it and even the
stars of arrow this weekend we're
talking about like he would be amazing
in an arrow movie he was totally ready
to do it
Grant Gustin was ready to kill it as the
flash in the movies but then we kind of
know how that went down the movie people
took a hard pass on TV actors oh they're
not popular enough they don't have a big
enough fanbase but the good thing about
all this is that now that Geoff Johns is
kind of like the Kevin Feige of DC
Comics movies I think he'll be able to
help a little bit with that but there's
still people above him that make those
decisions so if his boss like the
president of Warner Brothers says no I
don't want this TV actor in one of my
movies then there's nothing he can do
about it he's really there to fix the
movies I think he tries to help out as
much as he can with the TV shows but now
that he's writing a Batman movie with
Ben Affleck which I'm so excited about
and he's in charge of shepherding all
these other DC movies I don't think he's
gonna have time to do as much stuff with
the TV shows Annie's not even supposed
to be writing comics for the next year
or two at least I don't know beyond that
he'll probably write more comics
eventually but they said that because
he's taking on this new role he's not
going to be riding a
lotta comics but let me know in the
comments what do you think about the
movies completely sidelining the TV
shows version of Task Force X don't even
call it the Suicide Squad they could
have still called it Task Force X on the
Suicide Squad they could have worked for
Argus they could have just mixed and
matched some of the characters there's a
lot of characters that have been a part
of the Suicide Squad the movies could
have done their thing the TV shows could
have done their thing they're supposed
to be separate so why then is it such a
big deal that the TV shows aren't
allowed to do movie characters I think
is generally accepted that if a
character is big enough they're not
going to be on the TV shows like you
understand that Batman and Superman
aren't going to be on the TV shows
that's kind of been the thing since
Smallville went off the air like okay we
get it we're not gonna do like the two
biggest characters in DC Comics history
but you do feel like you're taking it in
the butt a little when the movies won't
even let the TV shows do minor
characters like oh no we're thinking
about doing that character so you're not
allowed to use them even though our
movie will come out for about six years
if you remember the arrow even had a
version of Harley Quinn that at the last
minute they were forced to remove
because they knew it wasn't gonna be a
big thing they knew that DC wasn't gonna
let them do a big Harley Quinn Ark but
if anybody asks cute if Harley Quinn has
ever been on arrow you can say yes she
was definitely in there but the other
big thing this is more of an arrow
Suicide Squad video but a lot of you
have asked what's gonna happen with the
flash movie when they do that is the
flash TV show gonna have to go away
absolutely not the flash is a slightly
different example because that show is
so strong and so popular I think by the
time we get to the flash movie that they
won't have as many problems doing movie
characters because the biggest villain
for the flash is the reverse-flash and
they've already done him on the flash TV
show so it's not like the movie people
are gonna make them retroactively
Liebeck that out it's just I think they
tried not to do the exact same thing
that the movies are doing in the TV show
changes so many things about the comics
like it mixes and matches I don't think
it's gonna be a big issue but here's my
other big question do you think that by
the time we get to some of these movies
and like five or six years do you think
we'll actually start seeing some of the
TV characters in the DC films now Marvel
stuff is a completely different
situation because DC hasn't got to the
point where their shared universe is as
big as Marvel's so I feel like there's
more potential for DC TV characters to
make it to screen just because the TV
shows are already doing some really big
Justice League level
characters a giveaway time
congratulations to this week's giveaway
winner Jean - ro you and a $20 Amazon
gift card be sure to private message me
on the back end of my channel so I can
get your contact details that's just on
the about page and there's a new round
of the giveaway that starts now all you
have to do to enter is be a subscriber
and leave a comment on this video
there'll be a bunch of DC and Marvel
stuff this week I've done a bunch of
Game of Thrones this weekend so I want
to take like a quick break but there are
a couple big Game of Thrones videos that
I want to do so I'm gonna sandwich them
in between a couple comic book videos so
really big stuff happening this week and
Stephen Amell is playing Casey Jones and
Ninja Turtles so be sure to go see Ninja
Turtles this weekend while you guys wait
for my next video to post you can click
here for all my x-men apocalypse Easter
eggs and you can click here for my Game
of Thrones video from last night thank
you so much for watching everybody let's
high five I'll see you guys tonight